[Musik]
dritter oktober 2020 ein großer tag für
53 berufs und 24
offiziere nach einer mehrjährigen
ausbildung an der theresianischen
militärakademie in wiener neustadt
muster die soldaten des jahrgangs
hauptmann neusser erleichtert aus unter
den gästen sind auch
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
und bundespräsident alexander van der
bellen
meine damen und herren leute nannte sie
beenden mit dem heutigen tag ihre
ausbildung an der militärakademie zu
werden in den unterschiedlichsten
funktionen verantwortung übernehmen
sie werden nationale und auch
internationale dazu beitragen dass reden
und sicher in unserem länge und in
europa erhalten bleiben
sie bekennen sich zu den demokratischen
werten und haben gelernt als offiziere
stets den menschen in den mittelpunkt
die herstellungs- und brandls zu stellen
und die strafen heute dafür danken dass
sie als berufsoffizier unserer republik
auch verteidigungsminister in klaudia
tanner gratulierten soldaten zu ihrem
erbrachten
sehr geehrte leutnant miliz
berufsoffizier ist gratuliere ihnen zu
erfolgreichen absolvierung der
offiziersausbildung und der damit
verbundene beförderung zu merken
sie beginnen nun einen neuen abschnitt
in ihrer militärischen laufbahn sie
treten ein in neue zeiten
dazu wünsche ich ihnen erfolg und
erfüllung und das hierzu notwendige
soldaten auf die traditionelle
militärparade und dasburg auf konzert
muss der diesjährige jahrgang leider
verzichten
der festakt findet ihn stark
eingeschränkter form und unter
mittlerweile standardmäßigen coroner
sicherheitsmaßnahmen statt nachdem
[Musik]
treueeid werden die neuen offiziere
darunter auch fünf frauen den
bundespräsidenten und der
bundesministerin persönlich vorgestellt
[Musik]